في اتجاه اخر معروف عنك دائما
وهكذا نسمع مواقفك الحذره من العولمه الا
ترى انه تعيين ريشه سوناك وايضا قبله
تعيين صادق خان عمده لندن تفند مثل هذه
الاراء
ربما
بانه يمثل العولمه كما كان برجا مثلا خط
انسحب منها
وكان من مؤيديه وقد الانتخابات كان ملتزمه
حتى قبل ان تكون له شعبيه كبيره همم اعتقد
بان لديه عقليه العولمه ربما اكون مخطا
وحتى من المحتمل انه سيحتضمن الكثير من
اذكار العولمه
كثير همم
المشاكل بدات تتصاعد في بريطانيا وهذه
الازمه في بريطانيا بدات تتعمق مع بريزه
وليس مع العوده يعني بريزه الذي يتحمل
المسؤوليه
باورصه في الاتحاد الاوروبيه
بشكل اساسي يقول باننا ندعم منظمه سياسيه
لا تصب في مصلحه اوروبا باكملها نحن
نستطيع العمل مع الدول الاوروبيه وهذا ما
نفعله غالبا ولا يوجد سبب يمنعنا من
الوحده مع اوروبا لا شيء في بركزه همم
يقفوا الضروره ضد التعاون الدوري كما
شاهدنا اسف بالمثال مع الناس عليك
اوكرانيا مع روسيا والعديد من الدول
الاوروبيه اجتمعت
لمقاومتي ما يجري بغض النظر عن العضويه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي الدول الاتحاد الكبيره
لم تكن جزءا من هذه الجهود فلا اعتقد بان
الاتحاد الاوروبيه يمثل اوروبا ولا اعتقد
انه يمثل التعاون اظن اوروبا
براك زد تمنعنا من عمل في اوروبا